why has Cher never done Watch What
Happens Live oh she did years ago yeah
but Madonna you say Madonna still has
not done the show I hope she does and
this bothers you I could see in your
diary I'm actually kind of over it
because I feel like in my notes app I
was keeping a long list of interview
questions for her in case she ever did
the show and it's kind she's kind of
answered a lot of it I I'm kind of
I've kind of gotten you know it's not
I've mellowed about this I've mellowed
about it now she and I have been in
touch a little bit over the years and
she said to me
a couple years ago I reached out to her
and said oh Anderson and I are coming to
see you tonight she was doing like a
special surprise performance for
something and she said to me
stop having people trash me on your show
something like that and I said Madonna I
go because there's just been something
where someone said something and it got
picked up and I said I speak so
positively I am such a fan of yours on
the radio and on Watch What Happens Live
only the bad stuff gets picked up that's
what gets picked up in the Press you
know how this works I could make a four
hour Montage of me licking Madonna's ass
on Watch What Happens Live or on the
radio on the on Andy's Kiki Lounge
Channel 312 on your SiriusXM app every
75 minutes there is the Madonna song
that's how many Madonna songs there are
in the in the queue so that's how big of
a fan I am